paris brest 6 117 km 7 jours pour relier
la ville du finistère le périple du
jeune gamin a débuté dimanche 22 avril
depuis le vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines une enceinte
que le passionné de vélo a pu visiter
avec son papa et son grand-père qui
l'accompagnent dans cette initiative
celle excité j'ai hâte à des partir
parce que ça fait longtemps qu'on
prépare bien mon grand père qui me
parlait souvent bas de ces paris brest
paris et de sa et du coup bah j'ai
essayé de faire du vélo et c'est
formidable de l'accompagner vais lui
faire plaisir
puisqu'on a fait des randonnées en somme
tous les deux soit dans la région de
brest voit dans les alpes et c'est
toujours un plaisir d'être avec lui puis
l'entraîné de discuter de s'arrêter on
est assez admiratif de sa volonté qu'il
a alors il faut quand même savoir qu'on
va rester on va rouler tranquillement on
va pas on va pas rentrer dans l'effort
donc ça va très très bien se passer pour
lui une performance sportive pour cet
enfant de 10 ans une initiative surtout
solidaire pour aider la lutte contre la
mucoviscidose
une amie de la famille est touchée par
la maladie pendant son trajet gabin va
donc récolter des fonds pour une
association
il a fait que ce soit un enfant je
trouve qu'il représente les valeurs de
la lutte contre la mucoviscidose c'est à
dire il donne son souffle déjà un
souffle énorme
il donne son dynamisme sa persévérance
son courage et donc je trouve ça
formidable qu'un enfant seule après une
halte par le club de cyclotourisme de
maurepas le trio de cyclistes
s'embarquent dans l' aventure un tracé
qui empruntent celui du paris brest
paris randonneur
c'est un parcours exigeant ainsi 117 km
qui va traverser le perche la mayenne et
qui va finir sur la bretagne avec pas
mal de dénivelé quand même direction
senonches dans l'eure et loir pour une
première étape d'une centaine de
kilomètres et gabin devrait arriver à
brest samedi 28 avril